thank you
thank you so much
you know what it's great you're beloved
but at the same time i know that you
must get it must be harder it's a curse
to be beloved
and you go into a men's room you're
trying to use the urinal guy next to you
norm
yeah yeah that's a tough one
uh listen first of all happy holidays
thank you same to you thank you for for
doing this and i don't think people at
home uh realize that that when you're
doing one of these shows a lot of guests
won't make the time in the holiday
season and they won't because i always
have time for you oh is that sweet and
you know what
look he died who wouldn't but especially
on top of that on top of that it's not
like you're you're not doing anything
it's not like you're not busy uh you're
doing this broadway show art right right
now and you got to be very busy with
that yeah and you know my whole family
has come in to
join me to watch me i guess do art to
make my broadway debut that's cool are
they here in new york city yeah actually
i had to bring them with here tonight
because you know i mean we were all
supposed to be having dinner together
and uh but i i thought i'd make time for
your show instead but if you don't mind
if we could do the both together could
my whole family have their holiday
dinner my mom brought a bunch of turkey
and stuff would that be okay conan could
you just do the whole thing over here
come on come on why don't we why don't
we uh
why don't we bring him out here first
and meet him do you want to meet him
first sure let's meet your family who's
here is this like okay uh that's my wife
bernadette yeah
and my mom and my sister kathy
and loretta and marty
and nancy
hey
[Applause]
oh okay good enough fine that's great
okay that works okay there it is
jason christian come on everybody all
out
i can't believe it oh come on
[Applause]
george how many people did you bring i
brought uh like uh 30 i think
you bring there's tomorrow at home but
uh he's the ones who made it yes that's
nice my god i can't believe you know all
their names that's amazing come on now
let's go over and have some turkey come
on we're gonna do it over here yeah yeah
we're gonna do the whole thing over here
all right we'll do the interview over
here while your family has turkey this
will be nice folks great
okay
hi everybody hey
hey sure
[Applause]
uh over there at the kids table
please ready thank you
he's a good sport to do that all right
let's uh he is this is great yeah
all right thank you okay
this is great all right well uh hold on
hold on let's i'd like to start this off
uh but i'm conan hi good to see you
um i thought what we're going to do is
the interview right here while you're
all having your holiday meal we can kill
two birds with one stone is that okay
okay this is cool
all right so tell us uh you're doing
this show art yeah is that right is it
is is it going well do you like being in
the city judd hirsch and joe morton are
uh are doing it with me and they are
just so awesome the two of them hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey
can we please just you know
keep it down we're trying to do the
interview thank you oh it's just yeah
it's for tv so yeah yeah yeah great
all right now this has been a dream of
yours always to do broadway yeah well
who wouldn't want to do broadway it's
sort of the pinnacle of the whole show
business experience and hey jason jason
j j j
come on relax can you find a regular
knife so we can do the interview oh
okay
television's affable bar fly norm
i'll just sit down and shut up
you know maybe this isn't the best idea
it seems like there's some tension no no
no that's fine it's fine everything's
cool relax with this all right so you
like doing the stage it's like part of
the tradition yeah because you know
frankly i've been drummed off of
television so i might as well be doing
theater you know what it is it is kind
of fun all right hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey
andy
have a little respect for you
they started it
gets excitable around i have an idea
everybody why what if what if you showed
a clip do you have a clip no see that's
the thing with theater you know it's the
magic of the live experience
uh i do i do have a clip with george
liz honey do you want to roll that
clip
oh toto i don't think we're in kansas
anymore
oh and comedy lion don't worry i won't
let the wicked witch get you or you
scarecrow are you tin man
please auntie m and yeah
jake jason come here damn it
hey hey
give me that
i'll kill you okay ted i told you to
destroy that tent george i can't believe
you brought that tape on national
conference
please don't start in on jason again
please
be sensitive sensitive
well shut up
you shut
please please stop it would you all of
you just settle down and please mrs went
you have got to shut up
[Applause]
i have an announcement
i think i may be gay
[Applause]
i could weep
oh
i don't believe this
[Applause]
i'm sorry conan i'm really sorry i
family i'm i'm i'm i'm worried about you
i mean this was
kind of a disaster are you all right i'm
okay i guess but i mean i can't believe
that
they just
everyone gets so intense about the
holidays i know i know it's terrible
i just wish there was a place you know
where we could all just relax all just
chill out a place somewhere you could go
where where everybody
knew your name
and
they were always glad you came
[Music]
you know i
i think i know what you're talking about
you're talking about a place like cheers
you know the cheers
bar
no conan
i'm referring to the land of oz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
once
all right i don't know what the hell's
going on uh we're gonna take a little
break
george went everybody we'll be right
back